hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to to make
a creepy idea charming doesn't make it
charming it makes it more creepy and I
think anyone can say that up today's
bill Milton a bunch of little boys want
to see a grown prostitute named charmed
yet yes it can only go downhill from
there how the hell are you supposed to
have a whimsical Semite family comedy
established when fat your frigging stuff
who says they do not me let's get this
over with milk money so how does this
charming little romp of a movie begin
anyway imports knees at the same time
and and Melanie Griffith's name over
that and we're off to a good start it
turns out a bunch of boys are having a
girls slumber party complete with
giggling talking about brushes and
having no fucking clue what the hell
they're talking about
found it my mom's secret sure she goes
in the bottom of the bathtub to stop the
drain no it doesn't it's a diaphragm I
think it's a travel drinking cup or
maybe isn't she joke I found it in my
sister's room
I believe it's some kind of weapon okay
let my born a chick because even I knew
what these things were at that age just
because we're boy doesn't he we're total
friggin moron
what's this I don't know but it was a
cover miss ancient alien tribes and
let's try to milk it boom
yeah they can play around
and
laughter the charming flashlight food
scene we cooked to our main kid named
Frank and his dad played by Ed Harris it
turns out Frank is studying sex
education in school he's having a little
bit of trouble there sign this but I'm
getting known with it you can't relate
that to the real world
myself like with mono virgin when you
married her
why is everything what I seem like that
habit are you gonna tell me about more
moolah no so he goes to one of those
schools where the kids conveniently have
no copyrighted images on their clothes
as we see our three little heroes are
pretty damn obsessed about this whole
sex thing what are we looking at oh and
they want for two did I mention that
Bart what's that I think it's an elbow
will you stop reading why do you do that
my daddy man complete order and
sanitation okay here's the thing if you
want to talk about a kid's sexual
discovery that's fine but they're doing
it in such a cutesy way do it in an
adult movie this is not the right way to
handle it oh don't believe me don't
believe me that's overly sappy and
cutesy well let's take a look at the
three kids here you got one kid always
telling jokes another kid was concerned
with being clean and the last kid who is
obsessed with this leather jacket and
good-looking hair sound familiar
[Music]
that's right if you wanted to hear the
equivalent of whole house talking about
their sexual discovery get out of here
before I kill you I know a place where
the girls are naked all the time we're
guys can see naked girls all they want
24 hours a day the Internet it's all
over the place
I don't believe such place exists where
is this city they partake in
screenwriting class a number five six to
breaking the piggy bank with a hammer
when they simply could have just opened
it and they begin raising the money to
go to the city to see a woman naked they
sell their videos they sell their comics
they let girls pay to try to jackets on
then they finally get up enough money to
go to random where the prostitutes are
men we now come across screenwriting
cliche number two three five the
gangster and the techie Hawaiian shirt
and jewelry cash rifles you won't ask me
that never ask me that never ask me
about my painfully obvious business it
turns out he's the mobsters last pin for
Melanie Griffith character ve wouldn't
that be a better movie she's the kind of
person the boys are looking for but
don't know how to find really don't know
how to find how do we tell the prosecute
for everybody else yeah how do we know
we're not asking a ballerina or a lawyer
just got a ghost I'm sorry but they
refuse to believe that any group of boys
can be this commendably Dom I mean this
is beyond having no social skills this
is being an alien on another friggin
planet excuse me yes are you a
prostitute
what well if it's not a personal
question
you guys need some help I want to see it
make it leave cool how much money ago
one hundred and three dollars and sixty
two cents that'll do it oh really so now
these kids are so stupid they don't even
remember stranger danger
cuz that talk to you in like tinder
garden hell even this guy looks like a
cartoon mock-up of all those criminal
you're not supposed to go in okay
that's Oh luckily as proof it happens to
open the door right on his face in the
middle of a job all right
yeah laughter she saves their life the
boys wish to thank her in the best way
they know how
asking her to take her top off we just
want to look how much looking and as
much as money to buy you feel that
uncomfortable tingling in the back of
your neck that tells you you're going to
help or watching this that nature is
still human hold on to that okay
thank you okay pull your shirts up over
the edge
[Music]
okay you're not hairy enough you
dangerous I swear to god this movie is a
five-star restaurant menu up around I
wouldn't mind so much except we're only
on the appetizers but you take the back
of her apartment then well guess what
she does
[Music]
listen man I can't do it I want to be a
Jamie isn't a gentleman bring enough for
everybody this is the greatest moment in
my life
oh god the bright goofy colorful music
will suck out all the despicable
unpleasantness this movie is offering
some bee goes to that reject from Tony
and Tina's Wedding who's pissed off
because he know that his girlfriend and
age is gonna go lesbo in a year or two
I'm a person and I have 200 oh you're a
personnel Oh neither used to move until
I get back I'm a person I'm a human
being I know you can't tell it by my
acting but it's true he'll be a swell
and buying his car she sees the boys got
their bike stolen and offers them a ride
in the gangsters car it was nice meeting
you
likewise he was very well being a gem
man you know for someone who runs away
puts his friends in danger and pays
women to take their clothes off motor
turns out her car breaks down and she
has to stay in the suburb which of
course leads to the meeting of me and
Frank's damn who did I mention has a
dead wife
please well I can certainly see where
your son gets all his awkwardness from
what's she doing here her car broke
gasps delicious she's Brad's new math
tutor she gave me a ride home from his
house and then her car won't start
and just leads to screenwriting cliche
number one to nine miss reading the
other person's double meetings do you
enjoy it enjoy I bet you're really good
at it there's only one way to find out
boy am I glad to hear you say that
because it's the one subject he's having
trouble with Frank Frank you think you
could fit them in I'm gonna give you one
chance one chance to take the high road
if you are actually smart enough not to
take advantage of this joke then I will
have some me free little bit of respect
for you so go ahead what's it gonna be
are you kidding
at his age I'm afraid if he doesn't
learn it now he's never going to you're
going to help
that guy got away so after we partake in
the lowest of lows we CV walk around the
suburban town trying to make some money
[Music]
look at that woman oh my god that is bad
it is it's very very bad did you like
some company yeah did you hear that that
was bad that was very very bad I'm sorry
is this how white people act I mean I'm
white and I didn't cry don't wake up you
what are you doing here looking for you
hi Frank she spoke to me I picked her
but she never speaks to me uh yeah and
she probably heard all that you do she
aren't you getting Jesus to your friend
Frank I'm Frank's father sister Nancy
we've got to be going now
see you later that is bad
that is very very good
wow I've never heard a horrible
catchphrase trying to be so needlessly
nailed into your head since word never
Tildy find out that her gangster friend
has been shot and that the other
gangsters think that she stole a bunch
of money that belonged to them so of
course she hides out in Frank's tree
house until the car is fixed and she
complete town but there's even more
important things going on during that
story like Frank has to be kept after
class Oh your understanding of the
female reproductive cycle is simply not
satisfactory there's a movie right Li
needs to be said I'm giving you a second
chance by assigning an oral presentation
oral an oral presentation on the
material with footnotes and visual aids
due by the end of the week really movie
so blowjob joke's on that one
see I can fit a mint oh that's gold but
the oral presentation that that's just
too low for us to scoop just go for the
bottom of the barrel film you have
nothing else to lose I mean what's the
stop you from having the kids just bring
the prostitute
in the class okay I hate to do this to
you guys but this is another one of
those scenes where I simply have to do a
play-by-play first of all the kid knows
he's doing wrong so snows you're gonna
fail the assignment so what's the point
in doing fortunes biological functions
in child rearing both the food source
and head read second he is trying to
hide out isn't she
as in not draw attention to herself this
kid is literally drawing attention I got
her who wants me to go on third I
understand the boys being excited by
this but why are the girls getting
turned on
are they looking to be little props to
talk to what did this girl her reaction
priceless yes is a a woman well I'll be
just yes it is fourth keep doing this
presentation for his teacher and yet she
actually likes the teacher out of the
classroom whether she can't see it why
are you doing it she can clearly see
you're doing wrong so you're gonna get
in trouble anyways why do we even look
around and most importantly ethos he
locked his teacher out of the classroom
brings a prostitute to class and by only
God knows how many school codes and laws
in doing it there are no no
repercussions for this absolutely not
he's never punished his father's never
calls it's a news never week for
classroom he's never questions the kid
doesn't even get fuckin detention we
just cut to his knees try on his dead
mother's clothes truly another
heartwarming epically damning scenario
so in case you miss it absolutely
nothing about that scene makes any
fucking sense
what so God that ever hallelujah
dolly yet where's the Cardinal
so and everybody was guessed by well the
beginning of the movie that Harris has
the hots for me and that's when we take
her out on a date oh look honey it's
Frank's dad look if that woman is she's
a hooker honey Shh
assess every mother's reaction to such
an everyday line other by your daughter
isn't it a thing yeah brace yourself for
a shock get even more awkward and she
comes across wonderful old clients which
turns out is one of the boys is father
you know this woman son not as well as
we know each other mr. Swift you know
her father oh no no no no no I may have
a name wrong but I never forget a face
my name is G like the letter your
husband and I did business together boy
you know for a prostitute you'd think
she'd be a little bit more discreet
about I being her clients but then again
this is the same idiot who I put nothing
by her but me also finds out that Harris
thinks she was a math tutor the whole
time and so she decides to tell him the
truth about the tree house and her real
job what may I ask are you doing living
in my son's tree house take off your
pants
welcome why do I have to take off your
pair because in my experience men are
better listeners when they're not
wearing pants and I have something
personal to tell you and I don't want
you to be able to get away sorry lady
you know that things can be done with
your clothes right and it's about new
phenomena because 90% of what you do is
with your clothes that doesn't mean
everybody else is I'm a prostitute men
pay me to have sex with him okay well
then what may I ask are you doing
teaching math for seventh graders at
Bruce Wayne why you dressed up like the
ham your son bought me a hooker no way
he didn't buy me for you oh what a
relief
you'd like me to marry you no okay well
that makes it better so he climbs down
the tree house and decides to have a
conversation with his son with a past
fell off okay that's it unconvinced
think kids going to grow up to be Denny
from the room the social awkwardness of
sexual frustration is back to a
filled-in we now know why you so scaly
of course because this is contrived city
they patched things up and now he's
dating a whore good for him but suddenly
one of the mobster bosses played by
Malcolm McDowell gets informed of her
location and go better
Middleton yeah oh cool see Jana well she
shouldn't be too hard to find we feel it
around for a while with other travelers
of the night what we're after now was
the old surprise visit that was a real
kick and good for lapsim lashings of the
old ultraviolent he happens to enter
right into the store that be happens to
be shopping in and even though he's
standing right next to her he doesn't
manage to pick her up twice and hit men
to do your dirty working smoke they
actually can tell a woman from the exact
same woman wearing sunglasses so he
tries to flee town because her life is
in danger but pet not after showing up
to Frank Sokka bring the danger to the
children hi always say and Harris tries
to meet up with her but unfortunately
McDowell recognizes her car more than he
does her and follows it what are you two
running into it - I'm going to the shop
and I'm sorry I don't think they have a
softball here you might want to go Adam
this 8 do the and show me Oh so
everybody meets up at the softball and
they have themselves a little fight we
then partake in screenwriting cliche
number 33 the kitchen yes wait before we
take card is free writing cliche number
2 for 6 the little kids come musically
driving a cop
[Applause]
the wheel falls off and yet somehow
they're still able to keep driving
straight and then suddenly turn out
waiting the bad guy as the escapes we
see later that she goes to the crime
boss of the crime boss I guess and see
if she can get out of working for them
now of course it has to be a very risky
very hard to do process or I'll see
clearly cook just under some again come
on out goodbye my child
well to think I was discussing leaves
you will be an insult to those who work
hard to do things that are disgustingly
easy but wait what about Ed Harris
apparently he chained himself to a chair
to stop a big hunk of wetland from being
bulldozed this was probably explained
while you were marveling over the
stupidity of the other scene so we look
likely this this place goes part of me
goes with him grilled in jail um you're
under arrest
dad sorry boy what pieces of grass mean
much more to me than ever trying to
raise you as my son it looked like I was
doing a very good job anyway forget it
Charlie he's got the right to do any
damn thing he pleases going on deep to
the wetlands and my name that's right it
turns out be found the stolen money that
was hidden in the car I needed to
preserve the pile of mud from being
destroyed and to make it up to her he's
going to name the wetlands after her wet
smelly and full of algae so it just
seems lodger tell me I'm whispering
[Music]
and just when you think this movie
couldn't possibly give you any words
writing you know what there is a place
you can touch a woman that owns
everything where her heart my god did
you see that
holy smokes if you slow it down really
carefully you can see the devil's
actually trying to escape through that
mom
Wow now that's literally ungodly
horrendous
so that's milk money a creepy premise
with a creepy delivery I don't know
maybe this was made in France as an
independent building with a hard-r maybe
something could've come from that's the
quirky little comedy that gives a shrug
at every joke it's pretty unforgiving
you feel uncomfortable watching it and
just wonder what the hell's going to
happen to me dirty little people a few
years from well for most it's not funny
it's not charming it's just sick so the
next time a kid tries to bring a
prostitute to your classroom just
remember it could be melody Griffin I'm
a nostalgia critic I remember a so you
don't have to time was almost even
[Music]
game on
I was born sink running
[Music]
I'm going to the sawed-off